[Music]
this is the grill for you I call it the
Obama come on say Emma's Malmo the boy I
call this to take black machine oh my
god do you smell gas a little bit came
out but how's the nervous that's just a
quick oh you're the best salesman I've
ever seen I can see you being a
stockbroker like me could you give me a
job I wish I could my boss won't let me
hire I'll drop that little Mark
Zuckerberg he dropped out of Harvard you
dropped out or Piedmont high that was a
couple credits shy of graduating I got
to get my GED I'm the principal of this
school I can do whatever I want
yo ran my house are you using a blank
voice no I don't hear color alright
let's do some introductions my name is
Carrie I'm here to make a little extra
cash so that I can afford this morning
that I got but that's none of our
business
welcome to night school this book is
kind of thick I thought it'd be more
like a leaflet it's not gonna do the
work drop the class no I do the work
you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
[Music]
you're gonna be a financial analyst I am
gonna start immediately I have been
waiting on the Lord to bring me a
pint-sized little man who can fill this
out let me get you chicken from the Lord
you take that fist all right tenderize
your way thank you
are you trying to get your TV are you
trying to get your GED yes you can get
out my way be
my suspicions were correct oh you're
clinically them there is no cure for
what you have oh my god I got learning
herpes I got the gift that people give
it boy you did the black boys thing we
had it's not a black voice not a black
voice you don't remember when you was in
that meeting he was like we gonna get it
lit up and hear this meeting lid it was
very lit I keep it 100 when have I ever
not kept it 100
[Music]
[Applause]